let's bring in Sal Paolantonio ESPN's
national correspondent NFL reporter good
morning Sal how are you good morning Dan
I hope you and yours are doing well
I think we are we McLovin give Sal the
poll question okay would you rather be 2
and 14 and know that you're gonna get
Trevor Lawrence next season or be nine
and seven or ten and six and sneak in
with a last wild-card spot you know I
always like to go to the playoffs if I'm
a fan of a football team get me into the
postseason you never know what could
happen if it so many wild-card teams
that won Super Bowls and you know the
draft is a crapshoot
so I'm going with get me in on a wild
card explain to me the Patriots in
primetime sound I get tom in Tampa but
the Patriots are in primetime five times
what are we going to be watching with
the Patriots in primetime
two words Bob Kraft cutaway shot I mean
come on Dan come on that's what it's all
about you know build listen here's what
we want to know about the NFL in 2020
can Tom Brady win without Bill Belichick
can Bill Belichick win without Tom Brady
that's it period paragraph end of story
that's what I'm looking for to me the
greatest Super Bowl ever will be
Belichick versus Brady at the little
sombrero in Tampa all right to me that's
the the greatest possible matchup and
I'd like to see both of them succeed
independent of one another I think it's
a great great story I really do well I
get the Buccaneers because that's new
we've seen the Patriots and outside of
New England I don't think people tuned
in to watch them you know there's a San
Antonio Spurs feel to them where you go
wonderful a dynasty just not you know
big market sports and I think that's
with I'm tuning in to see Jared Stidham
this year I mean I am I I don't know you
know Julian Edelman at the end of his
career I mean Sony Michele but they're
in primetime five
times I I think maybe that but that they
have them there so people can watch to
see if they lose I don't know of any
other reason well I'll take the
counter-argument then I think people
want to see whether Belichick can say to
the rest of the world you know what I
can eat them with see them that's it
but I don't have to watch them I can
read about that the next day so come on
if I said the top five must-see teams
this year who's number one on that list
given Kansas City the Ravens you got
Brady in Tampa I think it's the
Buccaneers I think it's Brady in the
Buccaneers 1 in 1a I think people want
to see if Andy Reid and Patrick mahomes
can get back you know it's so hard to go
back and they have all the pieces still
in place and they're healthy knock on
wood
so I think it would have to be
Buccaneers and Chiefs and then we want
to see if one more Jackson can win a
postseason game I mean that's important
and they had in my view they had the
best draft in the NFL the best I think
their first two picks were both first
rounders they're gonna make them
instantly better and I think the Ravens
are gonna be tough I you know you start
to look at this and we feel like we've
got the season already figured out in
May and there's a lot that happens we
don't know there's always three or four
teams that are better than what we think
and there are three or four teams that
are worse than what we think if I said
gimme two teams that are gonna surprise
being better two teams that will
surprise by being worse than what we
think
how would you pick all right let's go
with the pittsburgh steelers i think
mike Tomlin's got it figured out mm-hmm
and he's gonna that seems gonna be
better than we think I think Big Ben
coming back from the elbow surgery
they're gonna be good they're gonna make
the playoffs in Pittsburgh they have
make a fitzpatrick who in my view
Defensive Player of the Year candidate
without a doubt okay so they're going to
be better for sure I think the Jets
are gonna be better than we think I
think the Jets are a team that could put
it all together very quickly under Sam
Darnell and with Adam GaSe I think they
have no choice but I think they'll be
better than we think in the AFC I think
worse than we think wow that's a tough
one uh I'm gonna go with Arizona
Cardinals will get worse before they
will get better I think it's going to be
tough for them to get better and I think
people wanted to see them get better
instantly but I think they'll be worse
I think the Houston Texas I think the
Houston Texans will take a step back I'm
trying to figure out this cowboy
situation because I love the Cowboys
last year loved him
I had the only question market I had was
coaching were they gonna take the next
step now you got Mike McCarthy in there
but I don't have dak Prescott in there
we don't have offseason workouts I just
don't know if they hit the ground
running
are you bullish on the Cowboys this year
everything that they do Dan is based on
intricate chemistry on their offensive
line and they're gonna have a few pieces
you know that they're gonna have to move
around and it's very difficult always in
NFL training camps especially now this
year because you're not going to be able
to practice as much we don't know how or
when they're gonna get on the football
field in the summer the Cowboys
offensive line drives that football team
and if they don't have their act
together it's gonna be tough yeah I'm
just curious about it because it feels
like they have I don't know if they
really address their defense but it
feels like and it's a copycat league I I
don't know if we're looking at trying to
copycat Kansas City or the Ravens do you
think those are the two teams that we're
trying to look at and go we they have a
track team or we have a quarterback
who's able to beat you with his arm and
legs
well I think that Prescott is more like
Lamar Jackson and Pat mahomes than Andy
Dalton that's for sure I think Andy
Dalton was more built to do with Mike
McCarthy wants as opposed to what that
Prescott wants to do so you know we're
playing Lin we're playing option
football in the National Football League
that's why the Eagles draft jaelyn hurts
we're playing option football the
quarterback has to be able to throw on
the run and run that's the way it's
working out Patrick mahomes the second
and I like to say Patrick mahomes a
second because that's his actual name
and he also happens to be twice as good
as everybody else I watched him in late
in the season with those three comeback
wins he basically won a Super Bowl for
Andy Reid you and I can agree on that
Reid didn't win a Super Bowl
mahomes won the Super Bowl mahomes want
it because there were instances where he
was able to improvise in the second half
and the defenses he was playing were
static and couldn't improvise with him
that to me is what it's all about in the
National Football League but the
difference between mahomes and jackson
is mahomes right now is a much more
accomplished passer
when Jackson gets there Jackson will be
as good as mahomes you know deshaun
Watson is already there and that's to me
is why I don't understand why you tree
DeAndre Hopkins I think you give him all
the money that he needs because to me
Watson's already there but without
Hopkins it's gonna say he's gonna take a
step back talking to cell Paolantonio
the national correspondent for ESPN
covering the NFL what's the coolest
thing in your office there oh wow I have
a great collection of I like to read
about history and history of music so I
have a great collection of books I've
got probably every book written about
the Beatles and pretty much every book
written about World War two it's it's an
eclectic difference I get I understand
but you know Bellatrix got all those
books about football I've got all the
books about John Paul George and Ringo
if somebody says the Beatles aren't the
greatest band of all time your response
al Paolantonio would be take a you can't
you can't have mrs. Palin Tonio's
raviolis in my house on Sunday well we
had this conversation
Levin will occasionally bring up that
the Beatles are overrated and then if he
knows that makes me mad and then it
becomes this discussion that we spent
about an hour a couple of days ago on
the Beatles and their greatness but
McLovin for some reason thinks that the
Beatles are overrated well in terms of
orchestration and musicianship they're
much better than the stones they have 27
number-one hits
and there's no such thing as breakfast
with the stones
I think the stones are the greatest rock
and roll band of all time I just think
the Beatles like they're you don't the
beatles don't even get on the list of
greatest bands of all time like it that
they're you you start with maybe the
stones or Zeppelin or who beetles are
they're Muhammad Ali they're in their
own category yeah you're not even you
don't rank them yeah you know then
that's the tribute John and Paul were
like Mozart and Beethoven and Rodgers
and Hammerstein I mean that to me is
where you make the comparison you know I
I may be a pitch to the Centennial
committee of the Hall of Fame and I said
this is the reason why we put Steve
Sabol in with this father Ed Sabol you
know this ed and Steve Sabol we're like
Rodgers and Hammerstein John and Paul
they're like Belichick and Brady they
made beautiful music together but so
help me understand this with what the
Sables did in archival footage why did
we get to what 1982 to start keeping
track of sax I know why I want to know
what Deacon Jones had I I want to know
what some of these other you know the
fearsome foursome you know some of these
great defensive lines great defensive
players they're not part of history
because they're not up on the sack list
there and I think it's unfair to them
it's definitely something we got a look
at no question you're at NFL Films sound
can't you just go in there one night and
just start looking at footage there come
on
I do Dan but it's not at Saks I look at
the quarterback someone tell me what
what Joe burrows in for this year in
your opinion he's in for a hard road you
know because of because of the defense's
that he's going to play specifically in
that division the Browns have talent on
defense and they're gonna be much more
aggressive than they were last year
because of the change in the coaching
staff the Ravens have tremendous talent
on defense and we already talked about
Minka Fitzpatrick and the way that
Steelers defense is constructed so
within his division he's going to
struggle really mightily and it's not a
coincidence when you see quarterbacks go
to teams they go later in the draft they
have more success because you don't have
to be the star you can sit for a little
while you know this helped mahomes you
know deshaun Watson I get there's a
little bit of a grace period Joe burrow
does not get a grace period here true
was gonna get a grace period because of
his hip but it won't last long here and
you're going to teams that they were in
that position for a reason they weren't
very good if you were handicapping
though with these quarterbacks three
years down the road who has had more
success among the among the quarterbacks
drafted this year I think it's gonna be
two if he stays healthy no question
about it one we're playing option
football in the NFL he can move and he
can throw on the run very very well to
the AFC East is not as tough currently
as the AFC north and I think that will
be a major difference so it's great to
talk to you and hopefully we'll get back
to whatever normalcy is it's the new
abnormal I call it because they're gonna
be nothing normal about this but it's
always great to talk to you hope you're
doing well hey stay safe stay healthy
talk to you soon Dan thanks for having
me on the show NAT sound Paolantonio
from the mothership